hey what's up welcome back to the lobby
Marrakech is right here Borderlands
expert mary kay shy to say you play a
hella bunch of this game we I like
Borderlands a lot and big fan of the
series
how do you feel about playing it again
in I spent say an HD in next gen DX
jendi yeah all the whole MIDI on the
Xbox one or PlayStation 4 so they've
announced the handsome collection yeah I
which is God it's like she pretty good
deal it's got Borderlands 2 its gosh
Borderlands the pre-sequel which only
came out in October of last year right
and then all that deals is you see and
there's lucky does like to me like 20
different packs they had for this there
is a lot there's so much extra yeah I
think they should they have extra
playable characters they have actually
these like arena it's sort of challenges
they have these big monster boss hunt
challenges and they have these stayin
more loaded stuff yeah they have all
these thin like the standalone story
ones with like torgue and miss Scarlett
it looks a lot fancier when you put it
in a little box like that it looks like
it's its own set most those like aren't
will never see the light but a great
retail they were just like extra little
bits $10 packs but you know for the
enthusiast you know those are that's
actually a lot of content um you know so
it's it's really great for someone who
really enjoys borderland I'm it does
seem like it's for the enthusiast
because they're also allowing you to
bring your save over once it's within
the same sort of family has to be in the
family sixty xbox one yeah I'm the ps3
for for ps4 owners yeah this is coming
out sort of on its own $60 yeah there's
another version we'll talk about in a
second which is insane we also have
missed a crucial point or part of this
is that you can play it split-screen
four ways yes people this is like
actually I would say the only selling
point so let's do that one I mean there
are no couch co-op games for like
current gen you want play it you have to
buy notable copies that's just something
that's been happening more and more so
you put out a great video last week
where you had you're sort of like 13
best catch co-op experience over the
past couple of years
where's there nothing there it was like
next-gen only next-gen available doesn't
exist really I mean all the games now
it's just such an interesting
conversation like why don't they do it
anymore
it's because
money marry one because it's a lot
harder to way people are changing that
connections people don't like to play
local so much yeah they want to sell you
know more games they make you play
together but for people on split screen
which definitely this is something that
you need current-gen to do it's actually
not possible with last gen I mean anyone
who played Borderlands with a friend you
would probably have immediately noticed
there were some severe problems with
texture popping there was framerate
issues with two people but now they can
get four people and I guarantee you I
mean if nothing else in terms of like
how beautiful this game's gonna look
this isn't a realistic game right so
yeah I'm sure people when they saw this
we're like who gives a [ __ ] that it
looks nicer this game looks like a
cartoon it looks like a comic but it
does have edge mapping you know it does
have texture popping you ever notice
when you play Borderlands 2 that when
you switch to weapon it was blurry
that's because they're streaming in
those textures they're not you there yet
so with higher Ram means that that gun
is going to look smooth the second you
pop it hopefully because like when they
showed in the trailer they show the
split screen for way but they pop them
all in like okay that was probably done
by a video editor yeah and like one of
the sort of little annoyances about
Mario Kart on the Wii U is that when you
did four player the framerate was like
pretty decently chopped down like I'm
not sure if it was halved but it was it
looks so nice in like two players
split-screen and a single player but
then we did it for play I was like it's
a constant issue it's something that
Borderlands actually did really well I
mean a lot of people probably wondered
why did they choose it to look like that
you know they packed a lot of content in
something that played on a 360 pretty
good I mean you're talking about a last
gen system that had a butt ton of
textures and the reason they were able
to do that the developers were even able
to do that was because of the way that
they did this texture streaming and
texture lighting so do you run do you
remember that announcement because that
game looked completely different when
they first showed it off and Washington
till they showed off the sort of
whatever their take on that sort of cell
shading over to that's productive or
whatever that is like it then people
were suddenly really interested in as
well so hopefully that'll be something
that looks I don't that has been pressed
both ways as I recall P things like oh
it's made it a cartoon game
I was really hoping for this like gritty
sort of alien planet Mad Max kind of
thing and then they're like well I was
making it all crazy but obviously that
visual aesthetic and also sort of tone
of character and writing has been one of
the key parts of portal and success over
the years it's anonymous like they're
they're actually really you know that's
just something you think of when you
think of Borderlands you think of like
this wacky visual effects and shoot emic
face yeah you know do you think of these
like wacky scenarios where you're
shooting people and everything looks
ridiculous except for the water for
whatever reason they made it realistic
yeah it's kind of it's so it's great
it's like the what was the half-life one
when they did it in source and it was
just half-life but the water textures
were nice but the waters and so Mary Kay
found of Borderlands March 24th KITT
will you be picking it up this is my
title yeah um you know I think for the
enthusiast I I definitely have not
played all the DLC I think it's
something that I would be interested in
playing I honestly wasn't a huge fan of
the pre-sequel I liked the story of
Borderlands 2 better but I would
actually play through it again so I
would pick it up on it to play for for
Pearson co-op sitting all together on a
couch playing through Borderlands 2 that
sounds like a weekend that is good and
that's a good deal with all those Xbox
one controllers that you own oh good boy
they don't you can have four players on
the screen but that's another load like
40 bucks 50 bucks a pop nobody got more
Xbox one controllers yeah that's 60
bucks for the game then let's say 40
bucks for each controller that's 100 and
140 hundred and 80
skinned up why stop there why not spend
$400 on Borderlands by getting the
claptrap in a box Edition which has is
right there in the title
it's got clap drop in the bot in the box
it's like an RC claptrap yeah and it
comes with a clap true app nice that's
on your phone right and that's how you
can control your claptrap and you can
see on your phone but the claptrap sees
just pretty oh that is pretty cool and
it has all his famous lines like stairs
no like you got all the classic lines
I mean when I'm sitting around in my
room full of money
I typically wonder uh what am I gonna do
is much would be rate I've had a little
more room here and a little less I don't
know money maybe and maybe some way of
like spying on my roommates jacking it
in the sitting room when I'm not there
yay now my app it's a babysitter you
know
thanks a lot of people put a camera in
legerdomain you know thanks Randy
Pitchford like some kind of teddy bear
you know nanny cam mm-hmm but now yeah
it's really obvious and creepy as hell